hey guys cam here whether another gained
spot use update for you following the
surprise acquisition of VR company
Occulus by Facebook minecraft creator
Markus notch person has a notice that he
no longer has any plans to bring his
block kill the phenomenon to oculus rift
notch initially dropped this news Bob
over Twitter saying facebook creeps me
out he then followed this up with a post
on notched on there already expressed in
more detail his decision to cancel any
projects bringing minecraft oculus rift
Facebook is not a company of grassroots
tech enthusiasts Facebook is not a game
tech company Facebook has a history of
caring about building user numbers and
nothing but building user numbers people
have made games for faced with platforms
before and while it worked great for a
while they were stuck in a very
unfortunate position when Facebook
eventually changed the platform to
better fit the social experience they
were trying to build he maintains that
while virtual reality can be a suitable
platform for social media he does not
want to work with social nor with
Facebook stating that their motives are
too unclear and shifting notch himself
was a top level backer of the oculus
rift Kickstarter project in 2012 and
contributed $10,000 an investment he
says he did not make to seed a first
investment round to build value for a
Facebook acquisition the more jang head
is not the only game developer to signed
off on the announcement some however
like creator of sound self Robin Arnott
have been altogether more positive
speaking to polygon he commented that
it's very surprising but I'm only
excited about what that could be I'm
pretty sure it's not gonna mean stupid
free to play facebook games on VR that
doesn't seem real to me winner of best
response however belongs to indie
developer Chris hacker who tweeted I
can't wait until Google and Facebook go
to war with the autonomous robots on one
side and the VR mind-controlled zombies
on the other but what do you guys think
of not she's reaction to the acquisition
are you optimistic or pessimistic but at
the future of VR and dr in gaming in
general let me know in the comments down
below and to find out the views of
gamespot's own oculus expert Peter Brown
and use aficionado just inhales check
out their breakdown of what it means for
us to Humble
consumer and if in fact we should be
worried you can find this video undone
or reaction to the Facebook acquisition
of oculus over on gamespot com